what a deep confidence really learning
in this video I want to share view some
visualizations that will help you hone
your intuition about what the deeper
layers of a confident really are doing
and this will help us think through how
you can implement nearest aisle transfer
as well let's start with an example
let's say you've trained a confident
this is an Alex net life network and you
want to visualize what the hidden units
and different layers are computing
here's what you can do let's starts with
a hidden unit in layer 1 and suppose you
scan through your training set and find
out what are the images or what are the
image patches that maximize that units
activation so in other words passed your
training set through that through your
neural network and figure out what is
the image that maximizes that particular
unit activation now notice that a hidden
unit in layer 1 will see only a
relatively small portion of the neural
network and so if you visualize if you
plot what activators that units
activation it makes sense to plot just a
small image match because that's all of
the image that that particular unit sees
so if you pick one hidden unit and find
a 9 input images that maximizes that
units activation you might find 9 image
matches like this so it looks like that
in the lower region of an image that
discipline hidden unisys is looking for
a edge or a line that looks like that so
those are the 9 image patches that
maximally activate 1 hidden units
activation now you can then pick a
different hidden unit in there 1 and do
the same thing so that's a different in
the unit and looks like this second one
represented by these 9 image patches
here looks like this hidden unit is
looking for a line you know sort of in
that portion of its input region we also
call this receptive view and if you do
this for other hidden units you find
other hidden units
to activate in image patches that look
like that this one seems to have a
preference for a vertical light edge of
a preferenced at the left side of it be
green this one really prefers orange
colors and this is an interesting image
match this is red and green together
would make a brownish or a brownish
orange color but the neuron is still
happy to activate with that and so on so
this is nine different representative
neurons and for each of them the nine
image matches that they maximally
activate on so this gives you a sentence
that units trained hidden units in layer
one are often looking for relatively
simple features such as an edge or a
particular shade of color and all of the
examples I'm using in this video come
from this paper by Matthew Zener and Rob
Fergus title visualizing and
understanding convolutional networks and
I'm just going to use one of the simpler
ways to visualize what a hidden unit in
the neural network is computing if you
read their paper they have some other
more sophisticated ways of visualizing
what the confidence is learning as well
but now you've repeated this procedure
several times for nine-headed units in
layer one one of you do this for some of
the hidden units in the deeper layers of
the neural network and what is the
neural network and then learning in the
deeper layers so in the deeper layers a
hidden unit will see a larger region of
the image where at the extreme end you
know each pixel could hypothetically
affect the output of these later layers
of the neural network so later units are
actually seeing larger image patches I'm
still gonna plot the image patches as
the same size on these slides but if we
repeat this procedure this is what you
had previously for layer 1 and this is a
visualization of what maximally
activates a nine different hidden units
in there too so I want to be clear about
what this visualization is
these are the nine patches that cause
one hidden unit to be highly activated
and then each grouping this is a
different set of nine image patches that
cause one hidden unit to be activated so
this visualization shows nine hidden
units and layer two and for each of them
shows nine image patches that causes
that hidden unit to have a very large
outputs of a very large activation and
you can repeat this for deeper layers as
well now on this slide I know it's kind
of hard to see these tiny low
image patches so let me zoom in for some
of them for layer one this is what you
saw so for example this one's that first
unit we saw which was highly activated
if in the region of the input image you
can see there's an edge that that may be
at that angle now let's zoom in for
layer two as well to that visualization
so this is interesting where - looks
like it's detecting more complex shapes
and patterns so for example this hidden
unit looks like this looking for a
vertical texture with lots of vertical
lines this hidden unit looks like this
highly activated when there's a roundish
shape to the left part of the image
here's one that is looking for very thin
vertical lines and so on and so the
features the second layer is detecting
are getting in a complicated
how about layer three let's zoom into
that and in fact let me zoom in even
bigger as you can see this better these
are the things that maximally activate
layer three but let's zoom in even
bigger and so does it's pretty
interesting again it looks like there's
a hidden unit that seems to respond
highly to around the shape and the lower
left-hand portion of the image maybe so
that ends up detecting a lot of cars
don't say wonders even you know starting
to detect people and this one looks like
is detecting certain textures like
honeycomb shapes or square shapes this
regular texture and some of these is
difficult to look at and
we figure out what is this detecting but
this clearly starts you to detect more
complex patterns how about the next
layer
well here's layer four and you see that
the features or the patterns is
detecting or even more complex looks
like this has learned almost a dog
detector but all these dogs look quite
similar right is this um I don't know
what dog species or dog breed is this
but you know all those dogs all those
are dogs but they look relatively
similar as dogs go looks like this
hidden unit and therefore is detecting
water this looks like it was actually
detecting you know the legs of a bird
and so on and then they are five is
detecting even more substituted thing so
you notice there's also a neuron that
seems to be a dog detector but set of
dogs is detecting here seems to be more
varied and then this seems to be
detecting keyboards and things with a
keyboard like texture maybe lots of dots
against a background I think this neuron
here may be detecting tanks it's always
hard to be sure and and and then this
one here this detecting flowers so I've
gone a long way from detecting
relatively simple things such as edges
in layer 1 to textures and they're 2 up
to detecting very complex objects in the
deeper layers so I hope this gives you
some better intuition about what the
shallow and the deeper layers of a
neural network are computing next let's
use this intuition to start building a
neural style transfer algorithm